Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, during my Walking
Dead finale video I asked you all to submit
your WTF questions, so I picked 10 of them
to answer in this video with one bonus question.
I also have some gift cards to bestow.
Real quick, I talk a lot about things that
will influence Season 5.
I go into greater detail about everything
in my Season 5 Predictions video.
That will post later tonight.
Time for high fives though, congratulations
to Midoribishi, bokayjunkie and federico mangano.
You guys each win a $20 Amazon gift card.
I’ll message you all on your channels for
details.
Don’t worry, I’m still doing a weekly
giveaway for Game of Thrones episodes starting
again this Sunday.
So 10 more weeks of awesome.
Now it’s time to answer some questions.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go, Question 1 - bellez asks (no avatar)
Why are they put them in the train car?
Is that a shrine for all the people they have
lost or eaten?
Why do the people of terminus have the groups
stuff?
How far away are tyrese and carol from Terminus?
All very important things, the finale was
title “A” and everyone kind of thought
it was a reference to Alexandria or because
episode 15 was titled “US” that both episodes
formed this overlapping story called “USA”.
I think what ended up happening is that the
title “A” is just practical.
On one hand it references their current predicament
as in, ‘they’re stuck in traincar A’
and it refers to the Terminus itself.
Remember all those maps, and Gareth even said
that all the railroad lines converge there.
As in railroad line A goes to X, X being Alexandria
in this case.
Because that is their next major destination.
The shrine also has something to do with that
idea of the Terminus as a Focal Point.
Whatever their ideology is, it was pretty
clear they perform human sacrifice, ending
with the consumption of said person.
That’s what I think all those names were
on the ground.
Their sacrifices.
Who or what they’re sacrificing these people
to is unclear, but if they were just straight
up Hunters, they’d act more like Joe’s
group and not light so many creepy candles
or take the time to engrave runes on the floor.
Question 2 - Mikato Tanaka asks Why didn't
Daryl tell Rick Beth got kidnapped?
Or at the very least tell him she was last
seen driving off in a car?﻿
Daryl isn’t the most forthcoming person.
He talks less than a grumpy teenager.
Or maybe he still is a grumpy teenager.
Either way I think he conveyed to Rick that
her status and whereabouts are unknown.
You have to remember how flawed all these
people are, so for every smart thing Rick
did in this episode, someone was just as likely
to do something stupid.
I guess you could call Daryl’s an error
of omission.
But he didn’t purposefully withhold that.
It’s like when he was trying to tell Beth
that he was happier because her optimism was
rubbing off on him.
Giant shrug.
Question 3 - Doctor Who 50 and Beyond asks
Do you think that Tyreese, Carol and Judith
became Baby back ribs?
When I read this I actually threw up in my
mouth a little and sang the Austin Powers
Fat Bastard baby back ribs song.
No, I don’t think they’re dead.
As of that last moment, in the timeline, I
don’t think any of the Survivors had been
killed yet.
That doesn’t mean they won’t when the
season comes back.
Also, think about the cannibals this way.
You want the most meat you can get per person,
anyone who is a farmer will understand.
They’d start with the biggest person first
and maybe even fatten them up before eating
them.
They’d feed way more creepy psycho’s that
way.
It doesn’t look like they’re killing people
for pleasure, just as part of some weird ritual
and for sustenance.
I guess that means Tyreese and Abraham would
be the first to go, but we really won’t
know until that first couple of episodes.
Question 4 - Calvert Thomas asks Where are
they in Georgia﻿
They’re probably in Macon, Georgia based
on the Terminus map.
If you look here at a real life map, it pretty
much looks the same.
Question 5 - Bokayjunkie asks Was the whole
“new sheriff in town” Beth flashback moment
foreshadowing for something?
I think it’s just foreshadowing Beth’s
character development in season 5.
Like she’s going to be taking a new role.
Robert Kirkman said that we might not necessarily
see a lot of Beth, we might not find out what’s
up with her for a while.
That implies that she wasn’t taken to Terminus
and whoever grabbed her was someone different.
Everyone refer back to the Jesus and Gabriel
theories.
Emily Kinney hasn’t been demoted from series
regular status, so she’s not off the show
or anything, we will see her in episodes.
Just probably not as many.
If everyone is at Terminus right now, they’ll
probably spend most of the episodes there.
So if she’s somewhere else, we probably
won’t see her as much.
Question 6 - Cameron Peter asks Could Rick/any
of them, have talked their way into peace
if they had come as a group?
I don’t think it would have been any different.
Remember that creepy shrine, it said never
trust.
So no matter what, the Terminus people would
have never taken them in, and even if they
did.
The Survivors would have flipped their shit
when they found out about the human sacrifice
cannibalism stuff.
So they would have ended up in those shipping
cars no matter what.
Question 7 - Soy Taylor asks , During the
running scene when they ran pass some storage
containers were they're cries for help in
the background?
and did anyone else notice the trash on the
way into the train car, was it powered milk?
Do you think that means that Carol, Tyreese,
and the baby are already there?﻿
I listened to it again and it didn’t quite
sound like them.
It sounded like someone young, but not Beth
and a man, but not Tyreese.
I think they’re reveal who they are in episode
1.
Maybe they’ll be like redshirts to the cannibals
and will just ‘eat it’ so to speak in
the first half of the episode.
As an example of what’s really going on
there.
As for the powdered milk, the camera did linger
on it for an unusually long time, so that
means it’s an important detail.
If Carol, Tyreese and Judith are at Terminus.
I think it’s more likely they’re being
kept somewhere separate, not in one of the
containers.
But yes, I do feel like powdered milk equals
baby.
Fingers crossed that Judith is okay.
Question 8 - Cheap Munch asks do you think
Tyrese will have something to do with their
escape next season?﻿ How are they going
to escape?
Rick’s final statement basically lets you
know that they’re going to escape somehow.
And they have to get to Alexandria eventually.
Following up on the powdered milk theory,
if Tyreese isn’t in a container and they
let a few people out to question or sacrifice
them.
They can buddy up and start killing Terminus
people.
They’d have to have at least 3 or four people
loose, otherwise they’d be overwhelmed and
the other Terminus people would just execute
anyone left in Container A.
So there’s a lot of if’s.
I would say that Morgan is probably going
to help them out.
He’s supposed to be back eventually and
there was a rumor that Scott Gimple was going
to insert him somewhere in season 4.
Since we didn’t see him in the finale, it’s
possible that he could show up in the premiere.
He’s one of the few crazy people with the
intellect and resources to pull of a break
out.
So Tyreese plus Morgan plus Crazy Rick equals
escape.
Question 9 - James Kirk asks What if Beth
wasn’t taken by Terminus and instead by
Jesus.
So I already mention the Jesus Gabriel possibility,
but let me take it a little bit further.
If Jesus took Beth to Hilltop or Alexandria,
then it’s likely that her story will play
out at one of those locations.
Which I think is pretty cool.
It gives her an opportunity to become more
of a Carol-type badass, hopefully she’ll
be able to maintain some of the smile that
Carol seems to have lost.
But yes, it really is seeming more and more
likely that Beth is one step ahead of the
survivors in terms of big destinations from
the comics.
Question 10 - Oliver asks Do you think the
Survivors will stay at Terminus through Season
5?
So a couple of new characters were just bumped
to series regular, including Gareth.
So yes, I think we’ll spend several episodes
at Terminus in Season 5.
It’s just too big of a location for them
to just blow through.
Think of all those sets they had to build,
that’s a lot of time and energy to spend
on something you’re only going to see for
two hours.
No idea on which episode it will be before
they head to Alexandria, but plan on two things.
An extended stay at Terminus and two, learning
to enjoy being a vegetarian.
and one last Bonus Question - No Sherlock
asks Will there be a three way battle in season
5 with Rick's group vs Sanctuary vs Saviors?﻿
You’re talking about like the All Out War
going on in the comics right now.
No I don’t think they’ll pile all those
things in the same season.
There will be a ton more action, but in terms
of big locations and groups we’ll see.
I think we’ll probably only see one other
big location either Hilltop or Alexandria
and then just get a peek at the other.
They really do want to stretch the story out
as much as possible.
That means they can hold back on Negan, which
is like the next “A” bomb Kirkman drops
on Rick and the Survivors.
So thank you so much for submitting questions,
this was a ton of fun.
I’ll try to do as many Q&As in the future
as possible.
But my next Walking Dead video will be those
Season 5 predictions.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
I’ll be posting them later tonight.
Right now click here to get that video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
and click here for my season finale review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys again in
a couple hours.
High Fives!